let's uh let's get to the meat and
potatoes here on this story though civil
war oh yeah right what's the possibility
we have this from project veritas dhs
whistleblower leaks new joint
intelligence bulletin on domestic
violent extremists set in wake of
mar-a-lago raid i mean this is crazy
stuff here dves
information contained in this
intelligent but bulletin is for official
use only blah blah blah project veritas
released a leaked document today from
within the department of homeland
security which shows how federal
agencies are reacting to a recent raid
of trump's florida home considering the
trump derangement syndrome of people
like sam harris and then we learn about
people in the federal government who are
saying things like this
my concern is that
sam harris's level of derangement exists
within the dhs
and this is going to make things
dangerous so i know this is the report
that that that smeared you do you want
to give us a breakdown of what what
happened yeah so project veritas drops
and leaks this document which is sent to
like all special agents right it's like
uh
think about it like a memorandum or an
updated pamphlet to educate your special
agents in the field it's not supposed to
be disseminated outside of the
institution outside of their portal so
they get this and it's an educational
piece to inform like what are the new
trends and this one says both militia
and domestic violent extremists which
they use both of those terms and then it
has a whole bunch of different pictures
of different organizations including
my organization american contingency
which is is pretty crazy i again i
started american contingency with this
idea of bringing community and people
together that idea stemmed from uh a a
seattle experience where if you remember
uh
uh what is the the name of the uh town
it was uh the fake little town that in
seattle they stood up chats
jazz yeah so it was supposed to be a a
utopian
universe for everybody to flourish and
then it turned quickly into a socialist
safe haven because they had uh uh armed
guards they had checkpoints checking ids
and and it didn't work out for anybody
so they killed people yeah and when that
happened they started migrating and then
peaceful protests turned into violent
extreme protest
and for the first time it came out that
people who are law abiding citizens said
we need help from the police now my
company phil craft survival we teach
this idea you are your own first
response because whether it's breaking
your leg in the middle of a utv trail
um a natural disaster man-made disaster
you're going to be the first on scene
know how to treat injury know how to
respond know how to do something so
that's our educational platform well
when they didn't respond because they
the politicians told the police do not
respond because the political climate
won't support this don't respond
they put law-abiding citizens in harm's
way and i said we're going to do
something about it amcon american
contingency now what happened because i
talked to veritas i talked to these guys
what happened is
a special agent within the fbi
saw that we started this militia
organization which we were listed as a
militia
and this organization which they labeled
has a low
history of violence they called they
said my organization has a low history
bound we have zero history of violence
on january 6 people actually asked me in
the organization we're talking a hundred
thousand people they ask me mike what
are we going to do here i said it's easy
we're going to i'll release a statement
and i'll give you the guidance and
and i i hated even being that but i was
i knew i represented as a as a speaking
head kind of the guidance for the
organization i said listen group leaders
well we're not going to do anything it's
a protest that potentially could be
dangerous what we are going to do is
report all of the things that would
benefit people on the outskirts of this
protest so we can give them force
protection measures and intelligence and
information so they could protect
themselves so we could say hey the crowd
is moving into ex-neighborhood be sure
that you're aware lock your doors
protect your family that was the number
one objective
to be called a violent
uh militia and extremist by both the
public which is not surprising who's
miseducated misinformed but then by the
government on top of that
in the same week by the way
the government called us a militia
violent extreme group
the leftists called me a white
nationalist and a racist which is
fascinating because i have black mexican
korean white in my same family you're
literally a mixed race person mixed-race
person and then the far right call me a
bootlicker because i reported that i
even cooperated with the fbi um during
this time period not during january 6
but we had a guy who who said he was
going to shoot up some innocent people
i am a law-abiding citizen you come into
my public forum in my business in my
group and say you're going to shoot and
harm people i am going to report you to
local authorities that same person took
a picture of a special agent's business
card i don't know how he got it but he
took a picture of it and posted it on
our form which was on locals we
originally were on locals in fact dave
rubin started locals with the idea of
getting behind a paywall protected from
the social media sites that were
cancelling and deleting people
except we were big the biggest platform
on locals we were bigger than david
rubin's you're not on locals anymore we
once they sold
things started changing in the algorithm
and we it was too much for us to
moderate because on locals you have to
self-monitoring so
i started seeing the woes of even social
media i'm like how do you how do you
keep this this talk and the negativity
down so we migrated to our own server on
americancontingency.com
so all this happens in the same weekend
i'm like
i feel like i'm living in middle earth i
feel like i'm a moderate and i'm like
this is what happens when you decide
that you just want to go to work you
want to feed your family you want to
serve the country and you want to live
in freedom for the rest of your days you
become the enemy of everybody on the
fringes and that's exactly what we are
but the the fringes are almost everybody
these days
it seems that way here's what i say i
say like like evan hafer who owns black
rifle coffee a good friend of mine me
and him have the same social political
views on a lot of things in life because
we fought war for decades we come back
from that war and experience and go i
don't want civil war people were like
mike's taking us to war no my glover's
not taking you anywhere i've experienced
enough of that you don't want any of
that i've been to africa to the middle
east you don't want any of that world
and so there is a big pull of this
i think it's what it's ultimately the
people that are listening to you because
you're not on the fringes you're
actually just
logical
reasonable and you're talking about this
fringe ideology that's affecting
everybody and you just want to with the
truth bomb you just want to live
somewhere in between but the the the
thing i bring up i mean
look man
you've got the fbi right on donald trump
they accused him of being a fascist he's
certainly none of these things they've
lied about them relentlessly they've
just made all the stuff up it's becoming
impossible to be left alone and you know
my thing is
what i will say
they're going after alex jones with
everything they have because of his
influence
and they're going after donald trump
because of his influence because they
know they can't stop him this november i
mean look we just liz cheney's gone
carrie lake just won brian stelter is
out these are these are tremendous
cultural shifts in a very positive
direction which is all really good news
i'm hoping that if we maintain this
trajectory then we avoid
any kind of real conflict
but when you look at the lengths that
the machine has gone even smearing you
it's like bro you're the guy who's
saying quite literally please let me
just raise my family and be left alone
and they're not letting you they're
they're they're putting this this bolt
in out they're coming you know smearing
and insulting i i worry this is going to
escalate
to something you know
substantially worse right i talk about
civil war quite a bit thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you